Oi bom dia bom dia bom dia mais um vídeo
atrasado né Como sempre mas por que a
gente tá fazendo um monte de trabalhos
saindo tô cansado mais hoje nós vamos lá
publicidade em sempre aqui
vamos
gravar guaraná isso que a gente já vai
começando no hi-fi já deixa aquele like
aí embaixo
nem com a gente ver como é gravar o
dinheiro do da hora que acorda mais
tarde show quer fazer a ruim de raça é
né aí então colocar o velho tá
o Diego viesse é mano cortar os cabelos
fazer só é só na mata de porco com
todas
as pessoas coisa coisinha
para
fazer ligação com o tio que sempre está
de dieta E
aí galera que já preparou ela coisinha
para ela que ninguém nunca imaginou meu
de peruca
tem esposa
tá maluco mano
só de boa
[Música]
e quem sabe
Bamba
aí ó
eu acabei de achar o o
mapa que eu tava querendo mudar que eu
meu amigo tem que mandar para as cidades
né e sem foto tá rolando ali Neto a
gravação e ele mas
e
eu tá vendo que essa nova etapa não só
tirar dúvida mesmo você fez o corpo
Paraíso
Episódio conectar algodão são parte e eu
já tô preocupado com a quantidade de
comida tão botando para gente aí
e hoje eu não fui fazer isso paciência
começa conversando
comendo dizendo se quer sair de outro
frente não não
silêncio lavando roupa
eu
tomava lavar lá
vai colar aqui ó
[Música]
E aí
[Aplausos]
é uma história aqui que ele morre no
meio da história sabe como é que
posta como é que tem tanto você deixar
de região aí
eu gostei do seu joinha
Olha lá em cima olha waldonys e
o meu Deus do céu é isso aí
E aí
E
aí ó tô gravando aqui ó
e faça bem baixo que a gente tá
constando dos por trás dele para ele
pegar uma imagem de luta aqui vai cair
lá tomando a
o show de
E aí
[Aplausos]
e
fala aí valeu meu patrão
a gente que agradece Comandante yin
e
o waldonys É isso aí meu amigo aqui em
Fortaleza tem de tudo
sanfoneiro que faz manobras radicais em
[Música]
e olha meu pai muito obrigado viu Você é
[ __ ] agora a gente vai ali né no Theatro
José de Alencar porque eu tô querendo
procurar um lugar para poder fazer um
vídeo de promoção do meu novo show está
sendo feito aqui em Fortaleza né que foi
criado em São Paulo mas está sendo
prestado agora em Fortaleza e depois vai
seguir para a Europa depois volta para o
Brasil onde a gente faz uma turnê pelo
Brasil nos lugares grandes já tá tudo
programado pensem que tu tá bom eu tenho
que procurar formas de fazer uma
divulgação legal e eu pensei numa parada
que vocês logo vão ver nos Senhor até
compondo aqui junto com o Matheus
Gadelha a gente vai fazer essa parada lá
para a gente poder postar depois
resolver depois eu vou falar eu viro
vida tá bom clique em gostei não esquece
tem vendas atrasada aí mas eu vou botar
tudo atrasado no lugar é porque eu tô
concentrado em fazer um show agora
porque vai ser o melhor show já está
sendo o melhor show de todos os tempos
que eu já fiz em toda minha vida
e amém